a lot of people don't spend two weeks
consuming my stuff so they see a
headline or two and like you all hustle
this or hustle that I always talk about
sleeping a lot I also always talk about
like if you love it you know look look
anybody's here like definitely anybody
listening or watching if you really love
it like for real not like you're kind of
saying it because you're trying to get
through your life if you really love it
it truly isn't feel like work like
school felt like work and that was only
like 9:00 to 3:00 with tons of breaks in
between and that was devastating you
know my audio book reading it I'm only
halfway through that's work you look
like hell I was watching the video today
right it's not easy for me man like I
don't like it and so like I know what
work I know what not liking it feels
like and what work feels like you know
being an entrepreneur for me running
businesses putting out content doing my
thing does not feel like work I mean
look I talk a lot about hard work
there's not a whole lot of content
coming for me on the weekends there you
know I take four or five six seven weeks
of vacation a year like what I'm doing
is I'm maximizing my 15 hours a day
those during the week but I yeah
my only crypt eye is the health of my
family from the day I left school in May
of 1998 to this moment
I've always been an operating partner of
a business every day
every day I think that gets bitten by
yeah I'm okay look I think people people
should and that's life people get caught
up in sizzle over steak every day of the
week but I like that because I think I'm
kind of playing to that a little bit I
think I'm forcing that narrative cuz I'm
a fan of the reveal like AHA I told you
like I like being underestimated I
prefer it I I'm more comfortable in it
and so you know yeah I mean ultimately I
also don't care like the truth is gonna
speak like you're not gonna build a
billion dollar by accident business like
either you're good enough you're not and
so I know how this plays out
other than the health and well-being of
myself and my family there's no shot I
don't achieve enormous business success
in my life I'm too good at it it's
interesting though I mean cuz you say
that that you don't care I know you
don't and that reptile part of your
brain yeah very much admire yes but then
I have awesome on reddit Gillespie
assisting us and seeing you interact
with people do it all the time that's
something like 80% of your tweets and
replies yep which is staggering I I have
empathy for people that don't see it my
way and I want to show them I'm so
thankful that somebody consumes my
content that even if they say I'm a
charlatan and a snake oil salesman I
want to show the respect of them
engaging in my content to reply and have
the conversation because I'm intrigued
by the insight of what they're saying
I'm in tune with how I'm perceived by
engaging with people that started off by
thinking I was [ __ ] and I also am
empathetic I'm a pretty funny character
in a snippet two weeks full consumption
you got to read you know 28 seconds in a
stream in the right moment I'm not super
fun for a lot of people plus I'm also a
suffocate er
I will suffocate [ __ ] the reason I think
I'm helping people is I'm suffocating
[ __ ] like like no this is not the
president's fault no this is not your
bosses fault like this is your insecure
and like your insecure probably because
your mom's a piece of [ __ ] so we need to
talk about that
that's not conversation that people are
excited about like hey guess great news
your boss isn't a dick your mom's [ __ ]
up let's talk about it hey not as
interesting it's much more fun to save
my boss as a dick but that's not what's
happening so let's have that
conversation I'm willing to go there
because I think I'll win in the end
I think I'm bringing value and I take
people's attention very seriously and I
will never take it for granted and it
manifested in me being a kind guy it
also manifests as in me engaging with
things that hurt my feelings I'm super
pumped that my fourth-grade friends and
my sixth-grade teachers and people are
coming out of the Woodworks I am NOT
that thoughtful about it I'm tripling
down on Who I am
I was super charismatic and nice as [ __ ]
to everybody
long before I ever thought that anybody
would even know who I was because that's
my DNA and how I was raised so you know
it's funny I didn't grab you that way
like I get it and and it runs through my
mind I'm very aware that there's eyes on
me and now it's gotten completely
batshit crazy like it's super weird but
the best part is bro it's exhausting
playing a character I would I am the
most energy but I would never be able to
win that game because I would have a
vulnerability well it comes out it's you
will never win all this [ __ ] does is
exposes who you actually are
and so my just like people much like
them plus I like I like I like looking
because I like to learn from it like I
don't know it's just it's it's a good
place for me the world becoming more
people centric and at scale that became
a really good thing for me man like that
really worked out for me my impact is
extraordinary and I'm in a totally
different place and I'm really impacting
people and that's really cool like you
know I don't think people understand
what it feels like when people send you
emails about being homeless and now
being better or like like just really
and I really go into emotional places
with my entrepreneur
like I go to there you know I go there
and so I'm enjoying myself tremendously
and I'm very you know what I'm very
aware like that coming back and shaking
your hand in that moment like it's a
good thing it that people will
understand that I almost I'm having one
macro version of that with myself right
now
I know that doing all these right things
are gonna lead to some pretty
extraordinary attend I mean I genuinely
believe that everybody on earth will
know who I am
I genuinely believe that that's really
his brother it's not it's you have
understand it's binary
there's just no event even like I know
even a there's no event I mean I guess I
could hit my head like maybe I'm bold
like like maybe like I'd have some real
I don't meditate cuz I'm scared that you
know you know I feel in a very very good
place and I and I really AM exciting
about one core thing the fact that I've
become cool to a lot of young people is
a big deal because now I've crossed the
chasm into a different place where I'm
able to redefine characteristics of
coolness that excite me if I can achieve
making self awareness and patience and
gratitude and empathy cool
characteristics of an alpha male might
have a real [ __ ]
and honestly I have that audacity
[Music]
you